[Music]
all right welcome back everybody so
right now we are bringing you an
exclusive long crime interview with a
former Disney star heading to trial
after some pretty serious allegations I
want to bring in my co-host Brian Buck
Brian buckmeyer Brian you had a chance
to sit down with the defendant Kyle
Massey what can you tell us yeah Jesse
Kyle Massey the former That's So Raven
Disney star is being charged with
immoral communication with a minor at
first glance it seems like a simple case
the question being did come as he send a
minor sexual materials over the phone or
into it but after sitting with Massey
and his attorney this case seems
anything but simple
the fact is they're alleging is that you
knew this young girl from the age of
four and you knew the family and that
there was some sort of communications
that the relationship with you I've seen
them describe you as a father figure
almost to this girl and I love the
reaction because I want to get into that
as well and you were supposed to Marshal
her through the the industry so to speak
I've even heard allegations that you uh
supposedly said that she can come and
live with you from Seattle to LA with
you and your girlfriend and you would
help her in this endeavor I'm trying to
become famous and that what a month or
two after that invitation that's when
you were on her Snapchat you sent
allegedly some some photos of of someone
that looks like you who might have been
nude and and sexual photos those are the
allegations from my understanding yeah
I'm gonna try to give it to you first
what is your response to those
allegations uh
uh my response to those allegations are
that
first off we would need to go back let's
go back to to the mother of this of this
kid right you stated in your in your um
paperwork that I've known this kid
um since she was four years old right
well the the truth about my relationship
with that mother is that that mother had
a inappropriate sexual relationship with
me since I was a kid when I was 15. so
let me let me expound upon what Mr
Massey is saying so there is some
discrepancy on when the date that they
actually met
um the mother in this case is saying
that they met in 2009 Mr Massey alleges
they met in 2007. So based on Mr
Massey's birthday which anybody can
Google that's a 15 16 year old versus a
17 18 year old so um and then that's
where she advances this whole thing
about her daughter he's known her since
she was four now if you look at the
police report where she gave her
statement to the police she said Mr
Massey met her at Universal Studios
California
um Studio City I'm sorry California and
that she was with her children other
adults in a group and that Misty Mr
Massey approached her from the group and
was trying to get her phone number now
if that's the case then how would Mr
Massey have known any of the children
present belong to her
or belong to anyone else he's just
seeing you and a group of individuals
and and that's just using what she has
said I'm not saying that this is
necessarily the case but this is her
version of events that she gave to
police so she's using attempting to use
that if you will to try to set out that
he's known a child as if he met the
child directly he never met the child
directly there was no interaction with
the child is the video something that
was meant to be sent to like another
adult yes the video was like right this
could be something that is wrong the
issue but I did it accidentally correct
and the issue is that there's no feed or
conversation leading up to this there's
no oh let me send you something oh why
don't you there was no segue it's
flirting no no flirting no every all the
communication is straight laced when
she's saying oh my God blah blah blah
how you doing it's oh I'm good you know
how was your day
there's no no communication where Mr
Massey is to listening photos from her
or she's soliciting photos now I can sit
here and I can and I can like look at
you and say it without breaking down but
you gotta understand this was like one
of the hardest moments in my life
um because
the person that
molested raped took advantage of me when
I'm when I was a child is now painting
me as the predator
yeah so we'll continue to follow Kyle
Massey's case out of Kings County
Washington State as he awaits his trial
which is scheduled now for July